everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today are going to starting
a new series on one of the more
significant candidate tournaments that's
happened in recent history if you're not
familiar with the candidates tournament
the winner of that tournament goes on to
play for the world championship versus
whoever is the current world champion at
that time in 1971 we had something that
now we look back at and Noah is one of
the more important World Championships
in 1972 but 1971 the Canada's
tournaments we had the Russians
dominating the chess world from 1963 to
1969 we had Petrosian the Russian who
was the world champion and he was just
defeated by but a Spassky
and so because Petrosian was defeated he
goes into the Canada's tournament and
the candidates from it is different than
the Hallett is now now you have a group
of players and they all play each other
and at the end whoever has the most
points is victorious back in the day you
actually played a tournament and so on
one side of the bracket you had
Petrosian who had been the world
champion for seven years had just lost
it to pretty-pretty Spassky he dominated
his brackets but on the other side of
that bracket we have a young 28 year old
Bobby Fischer from America he dominated
his bracket just as much he won 606 so
in his two matches and so we have the
finale here with Bobby Fischer 28 going
off against the Russian Petrosian 42
years old who's really just trying to
get back to what he feels like is his
World Championship he defeated British
Spassky before that and he just lost the
title to him but he has had the rain in
Russian chess for many years and trying
to get that back so we'll go and get
started here with game number one but
that's some background on why this match
is so historic so many people talking
about the 1972 World Championship but
not as many people give as much credit
to how important this candidates
tournament is so we're gonna do that
starting off with game number one
Bobby Fischer has the white pieces and
Petrosian has the black pieces Bobby
Fischer starts out with E 4 and then C 5
the Sicilian defense Knight f3 d6 and
then pretty common familiar opening from
the Sicilian defense from Whiteside with
d4 we see the exchange after Knight to
d4 this is where things get a little bit
different than what we're used to seeing
Knight to c6 and then Knight to b5
almost everyone is playing Knight to c3
here but Knight to b5 starts to put a
lot of pressure on black right away and
one of the threats because black may be
tempted to play a6 is Knight to d6 this
is check forcing black to make a move
here usually just gonna respond with the
bishop taking really has to do that
after the Queen takes just putting a lot
of pressure on black he cannot develop
his LightSquared Bishop how he would
like to if he wants to get his not
involved into the game you could see
Knight to c3 white has just a lot more
options that he can go with maybe Queen
to e7 trying to force something I could
see him change or the Queen just to come
back here maybe Queen g3 attacking the
pawn up here a white definitely has a
good game so black usually is going to
respond with d6 so that if there is an
exchange here then the Queen cannot come
up here it's now protected by the Queen
on d8 that's exactly what we see in the
game d6 and then Bobby Fischer plays
Bishop to f4 now what's interesting and
this spot is most players are going to
respond with Knight to c3 and this is a
very different position if you kind of
look at this black does not control this
5th rank right here so usually black is
gonna respond with a6 and white can
freely bring his knight back here to d4
now in the game Bobby Fischer did bring
his Bishop out here to f4 and now after
pawn to e5 the Bishop comes back to e3
now why is this significant because now
we have Knight to f6 this is threatening
this pond Bobby Fischer would like to
play Knight to c3
but this is an issue because after a six
the night can't come back to c3 and it
can't come back to d4 because now this
pawn here is on e5 whereas before the
knight can easily come back here to d4
because there was no pawn and so he'd be
forced to come back to a3 not exactly
what Bobby Fischer once this is not
where you want your knight so that's
definitely not the position that Bobby
Fischer is looking for so he doesn't
play Knight to c3 instead he responds
with Bishop coming back to g5 so yeah
he's moving that Bishop around quite a
bit but now pinning down the knight to
the Queen Bishop to e6 and now we see
Knight c3 not my favorite move because
of what we already talked about that's
exactly what patrician played and that
is a six and then we do see an exchange
here on the kingside pawn recaptures but
then the Knights forced to come back
here to a3 now from black standpoint he
may decide that he doesn't want to
castle on the Kings side anymore he's
given up protection on the G file but on
the Queen side he does have some
opportunity to really put a lot of
pressure on white since one of his
knights is completely out of the game
right now
Petrosian continues with d5 and this is
really opening up the door for the dark
square bishop to come in and take here
on a three give his opponent double
pawns on the a file definitely at the
last place you want to have double pawns
now the pawn captures Black is down in
material but he does feel confident that
he can come down take with his Bishop
here and eventually get that pawn back
black can't take this pawn in the center
of Bishop takes Knight takes can't
recapture it is protected by the Queen
so this is all setting up for the bishop
to come down here pawn takes on a three
and then the Queen to a5 and now if you
kind of look at this you say yeah the
pawn could take here but then the Queen
can come down here take the Knights and
that would be check also attacking the
rook down on a1 while it couldn't really
capture that right away that's putting a
lot of pressure on white he would have
to move his King to a pretty awkward
position or go down a ton of material so
why it's pretty much forced to play
Queens
- and now the move that all this led up
to with the initial d5 move from
Petrosian and that is castling on the
queenside this now protects these two
pieces right here on a c6 and a 6
because the pawns not gonna take that
opens up for the rook to come down here
and take here on d2 so you can
definitely tell these players really
thinking at a high level
really really advanced tactics to figure
out this one subtle move because he's
down upon a material but he knows it's
pretty easy later on to capture this
material back on a3
and he knows both of his pieces here
controlling this turn of the board
cannot be captured by that pawn now the
bishop comes up here to a c4 once to try
to find a way to castle on the King side
of the board get some protection for his
King and also add some protection to
this d5 pawn in the center of the board
why brings his rook to g8 attacking the
king side Bobby Fischer really wants to
cast on the Kings side but it can't ride
away because the bishop would come down
to h3 threatening the bishop takes on g2
it is protected by the rook on the G
file but if you just play pawn g3 then
your works gonna fall so that's not good
from Bobby Fischer he decides to go
ahead and play rook to d1 this is where
I think black let white off the hook a
little bit he had a couple moves one
just rook takes on g2 I think that's
completely fine then you have the white
King for Bobby Fischer just stuck in the
center of the board for the rest of the
game unless he wants to Castle and still
have a lot of attacking going on here or
could have played Knight to e7 his
pieces are under attack but this still
defends and attacks the central square
here on d5 also makes it so the pawn
still can't take the Queen is going to
fall here instead Petrosian decides to
play Bishop to f5 but then after Bishop
to d3 we just start to see some material
exchange off the board black had a
better position he decides to go ahead
and exchange that's definitely not the
recommended approach you usually want to
be pretty aggressive when you have the
advantage he decides to bring Knight
down here
to a d4 now we see castle on the
kingside not as many threats he can
safely do that since the bishop is off
the board King to b8 King here to h1
wants to get it off this G file since
the rook is attacking and then we see
the Queen takes here on a3 now at this
point after all those moves from 10
moves or so ago black finally got the
material back he was trying to get back
once he gave up his pawn here on a d5 so
yes he did take this pawn but they're
now equal in pawns black does have
double pawns here on the f5 but they're
in the center of the board it's a little
bit easier to handle double pawns
especially if you have a pawn connected
to that but now one needs to figure out
how he's gonna connect all of his pieces
you can see his Queens kind of by and
lump-sum self right now and the Kings on
the other side of the board he does have
very active rooks those that's good he
does have the semi-open aji file so from
here we'll continue Bobby Fischer plays
f4 tries to start open up the King side
of the board here rook to c8 Knight to
e4 says hey if you want to exchange
Queens on the board and we see Petrosian
say yeah I will absolutely do that Bobby
Fischer decides to go ahead and
recapture with his pawn towards the
center yes they are double pawns but in
the center of the board he's gonna be
looking to push these pawns and he
recognizes this is definitely the way to
go with his rooks behind that and then
the rook comes down here to see - and
then rook to d1 - now this is a great
move from Patricia I always want to
bring your rooks down and attack your
second rank if you are black but the
night here on e4 is nicely placed no
real way for Petrosian to do anything
with this he has both of his rooks
blocking off a lot of the squares that
black wants to attack and so we do see
the exchange right here now this is
where it gets a little weird for me from
black standpoint because you generally
don't want to let your opponent's have
central pawns so if you kind of look at
black standpoint you may think okay well
we have the pawn here on e5 if they take
okay well that's fine we can recapture
with our pawn we have
rook protected so maybe you want to play
rook to e8 maybe you want to swing it
over here to d8 and start to attack your
opponent's pawn that makes a lot of
sense but instead he went for f5 and
then Bobby Fischer recaptured with a F
takes on e5 and now Bobby Fischer has
three central pawns yes double pawns but
that's not the worst thing ever both of
these are passed pawns and then we have
double pawns here on the F file but just
not nearly as strong from Petrosian now
we see the rogue come over here to e8
and then the rook to e1 protecting that
so now we've entered the in game version
plays Knight to c2 attacking the rook
right here and those two options you
could try to play rook to e2 or you
could play rook over here to c1 rook
over here to see one I think is the
stronger move after this night comes
back to d4 and then Knight to c4 and
there's no great moves the black can go
to the knight here has a great outpost
it's also defending this night here on
e5 how does black really continue but in
the game Bobby Fischer decided to play
rook to e2 we have some repetition here
with Knight to d4 and now the rook comes
to e3 he had the option to just come
back and do the whole thing over again
but he decided yeah I'll go ahead and
bring my rook up here to e3 and now
after Knight - C - Bobby Fischer swings
his rook to h3 and what this says is
yeah I don't mind if you gobble up all
these pawns in the shin of the board and
that's exactly what Petrosian dead first
takes the e pawn then Knight to f3
attacking the rook rook takes here on d5
and this is all to set up the rook
taking on h7 so Bobby Fischer
approaching the in game one of the best
to ever play he felt the need to go
ahead and have the past pawn on the H
file he has his rook here he has the
King here he has his Knight nicely
placed he feels like he can win from
this position so that's why he decided
to go and bring his rook here I think
the other move is
really strong but part of chess is being
comfortable and having a game plan if
you feel like you can execute that do
that and that's exactly what Bobby
Fischer did so the rook takes it here on
a d3 and then pawn to h4 really you have
to do this because the rook is
threatening to come down here to d1 you
don't just want to have your knight
coming back to the first rank it's just
completely out of the game so decides to
play h4 this is the past pawn you always
want to be pushing your past pawns and
he knows he can at any time take this
pawn up here on f7 night to e3 and then
the rook takes on f7 threatening this
pawn on f5 it is protected right now by
the nights here on e3 rook down to d1
check King to h2 and then rook to a1
says he I'm gonna go ahead and take this
material right here and then upon 2 H 5
and this is where things get extremely
extremely bad for black up into this
point he's had a pretty good game hadn't
played flawless and he's let Bobby
Fischer back into it but he just needs
to continue and take with his rook right
here then how does white really continue
can't take the pawn we've already looked
at that it's protected by the Knights
right here he could play Knight to h4
rook up here to a5 he has both his
knights and his rook attack or defending
this pawn right here and Bobby Fischer's
really playing defense right now I think
this would be a very good game the pawn
can't just come up here because Knight
to g4 check and that would also for can
take the pawn here on h6 but in the game
Petrosian decided to play the very very
terrible move f4 Bobby Fischer looked at
that and said yeah I'll go ahead and
take your free pawn and I should win an
easy game from here and it didn't take
too many moves from here for Bobby
Fischer to win because it's just too
late the rook takes here on a 2 a Bobby
Fischer plays rook to e4 it's hacking
the Knights Knight comes down and takes
the pawn but that's okay because after
King to g3 you can see there's just no
strong way for black to actually get
involved into the game after
Knight to e5 this pawn is going to push
eventually or this nights gonna fall and
blacks just gonna be down too much
material so game one goes to Bobby
Fischer and if you look at the bracket
you remember he won the entire first
series six to zero just won the first
six matches second round semi final 6-0
coming into this one
Petrosian who everyone thought was gonna
win been the champion for many years
trying to just get back to the World
Championship that he had just previously
lost to Spassky Bobby Fischer came into
28 years old and won Game one so
hopefully guys are excited about this
series one of my favorite ones to go
over we will be coming back shortly with
game number 2 to see how the historic
run from Bobby Fischer in the 1971 can
is hermit plays out but thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video